this is a production of Cornell
University you very much for that
introduction that disruption yeah cannot
be go further beyond that that level
thank you so much and also thank you for
inviting me here especially as the
kadian I back 10 years of lap is a
really nice video yeah last night I even
walked through some of the building
B
lot okay um so this talk I put
on my lab server so all this slide on
that server is called uh Z lab.net
share so then you will find the slide
there so you you don't need to take a
picture so you will get uh high quality
uh slide from
there great um Corell ranks the number
one in the plant breeding education
research so then what we do in this
genomic area essentially we try to
answer two complimentary question one is
explanation
and another one is the prediction for
explanation we try to in all day maybe
uh still now we have a kind when we try
to verify it colon it that's kind of
back word or we do not have knowledge on
those Gene then we try to find them
fishing them
using lankage analysis or G was then we
try to clone them again the for the
prediction you we maybe initially start
with the micro assistance selection then
try to do gome wide then maybe G was
plus genomic selection and maybe in the
future there will be the artificial
intelligence so that means that backward
and forward those approach they can go
back uh each other so then this GW also
help genomic prediction so then
prediction also can be used at one meth
try to validate the gws re so then today
I'm going to talk about most of this
stuff except the validation the red
color major Focus will be on the
prediction so then we will divide the
talk into the following section first we
go through the process from Mar
selection to genome uh uh selection
then we talk about the problem with this
prediction uh business then we talk
about the problem in the literature
there muddy water how we can help
everyone we see that clearly then we try
to figure out what's the reason that uh
uh on the hidden overfeeding problem
finally yeah maybe before artificial
intelligence even take everything we try
to uh do best improve of accuracy and
first let's talk about the Markus
instulation everything start from this
DNA then from the DNA we can measure it
with different genotype then we Cod them
one two 012 then we can try to do the
regression okay so then for this
regression we can have a two approach
one is the this sort
of uh top down so that means for example
at buet slab we have uh use this marker
try to develop the king shape then with
this King shape we can make a direct
prediction on those individual those
breeding value so then the skin shape we
can change it we can use some selected
marker or compress into group then we
can Dev a series of
bler oh another way is the bottom up so
that means we start from the
value of the marker then sum them up
then try to get the reading value then
those
distribution yeah we need to have a sort
of assumption then different assumption
create like a different basing approach
okay so then we can think about this
bsiness uh see how this River start from
like I said everything start from the
downway
East uh that's from Moren Hall Charles
Henderson get his first job as assistant
professor at the conel but he's original
s from s from AA State but he developed
that one uh all the way I think the most
public education coming from 197
uh during that period so that's a
blob so then the next one Tred to use
marker that one go back to A1 so rahan
Fernando yeah get this marker into this
breeding value yeah integral with The
Blob so then the next one uh
1994 that's the uh B breeder R Ral as in
everybody know
him and but unfortunately you that time
did not get a lot of attention for our
community
until okay 2001 okay uh mu and in go
that they publish this genetics paper
and basically they they
show how to use the entire marker
compared to the marker
how that is more useful okay that one
get a this community realize the denom
selection that's really big
contribution
um but still not get
used then in 2007 D he's the
corresponding author I'm the first
author and and Ro T hunter from West G
join
aser we actually we reinvented that G
block meas okay
and the good thing is that paper animal
science and animal read read it so Paul
when R then next year apply to the USDA
the da science uh da evaluation then
denomination B the reason is uh that
regression uh this uh basing approach is
Computing difficult and does not match
the existing system so then for this G
blob we just replace the pedigree
relationship with the marker
relationship so the coding is very easy
then that program get used immediately
then the next contribution is from
ignas and try to use existing pedigree
combined with the markr based pedigree
until now that's dominant the animal bra
okay then later on I did some um
Improvement on that kingship use either
compress to the group or use a more
meaningful King shape and try to do the
super
blob um un un like gwas method SO gas if
you method a is better than b
no matter which solution that's true but
for the denome selection that's
different and the order can be reversed
by different trait even different
population okay so then we figure out
the two factors
affect this which one is the best method
okay for example these two Factor
including the heart ability and the
complexity of the trade if the trade is
the Pol gen basically that's G blob
Works robust but if you have less Gene
then other method they works much better
and if the treat is lower her ability
then the compress you make a group then
you have a better position and if the
tree have a higher proability then the
base prod works best so really depend on
situation so that make it harder for
reader to use it so then we we build
this system basically is a machine
learning so then the machine will look
at the data try to figure out which one
is the best for that particular
data okay then for that evaluation
actually we have a
problem and the problem can be view from
this table so this is a paper from this
uh fing father Rex perado paper H if you
look uh this prediction accuracy minor
30 minor
40 so then uh
interpretation can be problem some
people interpret it okay if I reverse
the direction it will still work as good
as for example
40% but the problem that may be not true
and I can show why that happened for
example
yeah we do the cross validation for
example here is the five you can select
the four group try to build another
group and after this you will get a
prediction for every
Pro extremes situation is leave one hour
you try to predict that individual use
the rest then you just
look the
problem is actually we have a two way
try to calculate this this piercing
correlation for example on the left side
I have that
solid that is the group we try to make a
predict so we had the fin tab use the
rest to make a prediction so after we
get the predition that red so for each
group we can calculate the piercing
correlation
immediately so that means we get instant
accuracy so then we get a five we take
average as the
final but again we can also use a
different way for
each both after get prediction when we
hold we don't calculate until we get all
the file group predicted then we make
one calcul at a very last so that means
yeah we have that hold so there is two
ways to calculate this pre correlation
one is instant for each fold or hold
that means after you get for every fold
then you make one
calculation so in the literature uh you
can see the variation between these two
and some they don't tell you exactly
what happens then the problem is these
two are different for example I use adds
that uh 281 that fling time Miss as the
has I just shuffling that phenotype
break connection between phenotype and
dooty and see what's happening so X
expectation should be zero you should
not have accuracy because it's already
broken then we try to
see whether this two approach the get
zero that
expectation so I divide them into five
groups then for each group if you look
the uh the correlation for each group
and the rest that reference so then you
will see they are just on the opposite
side of the population mean okay so that
means if you
look somewhere here uh solid stand the
the test then the open is for the
reference so they just on the opposite
side of the publish me so then that
means they are 100% negatively cor each
other then the problem is the training
population if you have a higher
phenotype then you tend to have higher
prodution so then that's completely
reversed to the breeding value so that
means you supposed to get zero
expectation but end up for this
simulation you get Negative
5% so that means downward
by the problem get even
worse with number of the
fold you can
see so here expectation should be zero
but number of fold increase than that
bias increase for that red color that
hold
that
so the mold mobile if you have a jackn
like a Le one out that's the wor one so
actually ja should not be
used and so you can see can easily like
reach like a 15% negative for the whole
accuracy then you see oh the blue one
pretty good that's instant
that means you get a fold calculate
immediately then average that no problem
here but it also has another
problem so you you're intuitive you have
more training data then you have a
better accuracy right so that means if
you do the experiment you have more fold
then your training data is larger then
you supposed to get uh higher
accuracy so then you will see that the
instant that the blue one start to
having problem so it start with increase
with number of fold but at certain point
Dr very
quick why that's related to the size of
the testing population the size is small
is get B okay uh usually it maybe after
30 is sort of okay but if you have less
especially when you do uh like a small
training uh testing side then that's
really get a big problem the good thing
is for instant accuracy we have a way I
try to correct it so actually Fisher
already did this for us you a long long
time ago so then we should start to use
this feature
correction so then you see that U
uh a black line so then start to have uh
not like the blue one so they quickly
like uh drop so then that black line
that corrected inst accuracy then they
start to make sense that means more
training data then you have a more
accuracy uh the take home
message there are two ways try to
calculate this R accuracy p and
correlation both are downward
B then in
accuracy is uh correctable so then you
can use that feature correction correct
that instant method but uh for that
whole accuracy so far I have not found
the me to correct yet but this the
problem is in lure people still using
that hold accuracy even the Le one off a
lot try to evaluate the
accuracy so then the true accuracy might
be
done uh underestimated especially using
the hold accuracy on the leaving one of
that strategy okay so when the true
accuracy is law negative that peton
correlation could
appear yeah with unprecedent a frequency
and magnet that's kind of explain why
rex brados that result can have a like a
40% negative
qu okay so then we see more problem see
this
my uh yeah because Rex berado is
founding father in this area and try to
uh start with him he has a paper 2014
just the time I left Cornell uh propose
a
very uh
meaningful direction for the genomic
selection so that means the genome
selection if you have a existing non
genes uh you should incorporate that
into your prediction model that makes
sense yeah that
help and later on there are a lot of
research follow this direction breeding
program try to implement it try to
improve
accuracy but the
problem when the literature start to
accumulate people are doing lot of
different things then we start to see
rare stuff for example one paper showing
if you incorporate gwas result into
genome selection you can easily get a
twofold increase on accuracy for example
original you was 40% now you get
80%
um let me see this yeah you see that one
five time
increase yeah then we think
about that's true or not so then we try
to see if we figure out uh is any other
potential problem may be confounded this
phenomena so let let's see how people to
do this so then this one I label as a
valid prod so that means you go through
this process and you should be fine the
result should be reliable so when you
get data you divide them into training
and testing first then for the training
you start to conduct dwat then figure
out which one is assed with the tree and
with those one you calculate the
breeding value of the testing comption
then try to correlate with the phenotype
then you get accuracy so this is valid
so this accuracy
whole but uh the problem
people doing the different like they get
the data the entire population then
immediately they doing the GW then they
know which one assorted with the tree
okay so then we say whether this G real
work or not prediction accuracy is good
or bad so then they start to do the
validation so they divide the PO into
training and
testing so then try to see those are
soci read out what's the effect then
they do the
prediction then they do the
cor the problem is that the testing
population that phot tab is already been
used in this diagram so then that cause
hidden
overfeeding then they do this again
again but this is potentially can
increase your accuracy two times five
times or I just easily reach
100%
okay so then we we did like a
test so we yeah like we did before we
randomly Shu for the phot typ break the
connection between phot typ and G typ
you suppos to get accuracy of zero okay
so then we try to look at the accuracy
of the training of course
it's you look at the data already then
you do the prediction on the training
you get accuracy 40% above let Mak sense
okay then because nobody try to look at
the training
population then we need to look at the
testing population then for the testing
population here you see the green color
and the red color they are on the
expectation zero that approach is reg
regression okay they don't have a
problem they do they don't do the gwas
look at the data first and also doing
the gwas first then incorporating into
the prediction but is with valid method
so that means you divide the population
into training testing
first and they don't have a problem they
get expectation of zero but the other
one can easily get like a 10% increase
even should be zero and that's the G was
first with the invalid method then
incorporate into
R so that means the literature there are
lot of things tell you this really good
works actually maybe
not
and also from ad B group uh Al lier did
a really nice study and he know your
science how should be performed he used
the valid approach and tried to verify
about the 200 TR simulat to see whether
Incorporated J R can improve prediction
accuracy H is end up
with uh about like a
oneir yeah those incorporation do
increase accuracy but for the
majority still
don't so then the question for us is how
we
can improve
this procedure or improve the D result
try to incorporate into denom selection
to improve so then we need to
look this uh D was business first okay
so G start from
humans ER
glander is number one more publication
and D
okay okay so then uh in his population
he used like a structure the human
population so then you can look within
family try to look at the association so
then that remove the structure so that
works but that data is
limited especially in animal and plant
we don't have that structure so then
Richard is also Conn at the Sanford you
me this Q method then quickly drop that
false positive down but not completely
and and that approach is a slow then in
Harvard using principal component TR
speed up but this still have a uh for
the strong popultion yeah is a bigger
problem
now add group
Jing he has ref visit morison Hall and
we meet together we talk about these
things um help him quickly P that n next
paper okay so then J means
approach
is for the D Community now everybody you
have a standard you have a now
distribution it's not something inflated
then you can Bon it doesn't matter yeah
uh every marker I have a probably 10 to
minor 20 then how you divide by million
both test will work no then Jing City
contribution is get the whole Community
under control okay so then of course
that uh mix model pro has big problem is
the
Computing then the good things Community
can
help you see on the left side they all
focus on solving Jing's problem yeah
Computing speed and they all publish in
very good profile Journal like PL or
nitrogen
whatever then the question okay how we
can make a further Improvement on J me
two plastic model so that means we are
not only control falce positive but also
we want control falce negative so then
we see paper continue to com out with
different
strategy
including three method that's very
different from one is called
mlmm multiple mix model and the last two
Farm speed and buing so they use the
multiple lockers so they have a
dramatically different power than the
rest and so far we tested beting still
rank number one and you can test that
very easily you you go to my left
website you click research then you will
find like a gws
uh there is R code there just less than
10 you copy paste it then about like a
few minutes then on your default working
directory you will have this graph so
this graph simulated like a 20 gen then
try to see with different model for
example you can tell this model easily
at just tell which one to use then it
generates gr for example you start from
like a simple model like a general
linear model or miss the linear model
like Q Plus ke so they can find about
five or six but when you move to the
bottom for example FP or beating you can
easily get that one double you can find
12 like Lo
n okay so then this different method
method and for a particular user yeah
for example you work on biology you do
not read a lot of these me comparisons
confusing then you can always do it
byself you have data then you
just uh do not use that fix SE just run
again again so then you will
see which model find more genes in your
data and you can also change your model
for example change different number of
principal components as covered you can
also see which one fit to the
databas so then we
see yeah different uh
methodology then we see different uh uh
package for example including the tle
from add this group then gabit also
initiated from adds group so now I take
care of that one so then add everything
this model we Implement into the gab so
it just tell model equals whatever okay
a bunch of them then we also have this
IAD not IAD okay but have the same
philosophy try to make it easier this
one have a Graphic user
interface in term of how we can
incorporate this gwas result into
prediction like Alex Li
indicate that will use qk model then
two3 do not show the increase on the
pred so then we try to see what about we
improve the method whether we can
improve that one so then we can see on
the left side that's D blob without
incorporation G was without but when we
incorporate the
GM mix Ling model we see the accuracy
increase and even with a further
increase on the right right you use the
beaing you find more true genes then you
have a much better
accuracy of course when I sometimes I
say I actually means I refer to myself
and also my collaborator and especially
the people of the real hero they did
work and that's the the same graph when
I practice my job interview for this
position with ad I show this graph to ad
yeah that's how it looks
Improvement uh so that's
uh the landcape we have
uh maybe one Village in New York they
have a more trees than the whole area we
have okay very sunny and you can see
easily the landscape with that I will
try to answer some question you may
have what do you think the opportunities
uh I mean we're kind of coming from the
the bottom up that can identify causal
variance you know how do you think that
starts spitting into these types of
model we don't know what the what the
variants do we just think they CA them
uh so how do you think these models work
[Music]
uh one simple for
example uh your means with that 5,000
land races from Mexico then you show
there is thousand genes control
flowering time if you do flowering time
prediction uh compared to use the whole
genome
S&P uh with them equally build a
kingship doing the traditional G blob if
you give a different we for those S gen
then you will definitely get better yeah
by the way thank you very much for that
uh project so that save me a publication
for the
beaing um when I try to publish the
beaing paper is reviewed by Nature
genetics but when they see the real
samples on those 3,000
lines uh they find 50
45 uh the asservation compare with the
previous method like a Farm View that's
only 15 three times increase then they
get spare they don't publish that one so
then the paper was reject everywhere I
can submit so until you publish that
paper you show the result gen
uh control M FR time then I say oh my
chance came so I just use yours I divide
the whole genome into those Gene area
and non Gene area I want to see my 45
Gene whether I have more chance landed
on Eugene area actually it's get
dramatically enriched finally I
published that paper with that
enrichment gig
signs the season
right yeah without you then now nobody
can use
D brother so um you presed some results
at least as I understand where where you
kind of take GS and you use GS to I
guess influence how you treat those
markers prediction I mean how how does
that compare to like some of the basian
methodologies where you assume mixtures
you let the model itself kind of sort it
out potentially use G as a PR have you
have you done those kind of comparisons
yeah um the question
is uh the incorporation I show here is
different gas method with G blob and
those gas result was incorporate as the
coar in that
model and
my guess is if you do the same thing for
the Basin model for Basin model you
treat all the markers as a random effect
but you add some fixed effect just as
the way we did in the gum and that
should increase the accuracy of the Bas
approach whatever the Bas it
is but even even Beyond just having this
effect right so let's take Bas R for
example right we have mixtures of
normal I mean would it have you thought
about looking at gws hits and and having
that influence prior probabilties of
which normal distribution might so uh I
think um you're are looking for
different way of incorporation so my way
is try incorporate simply as the coate
with a fixed fact and of course you can
incorporate the different way uh you can
also treat them as different weight or
different distribution as there as a
random effect that's still possible okay
yeah for the whole
accuracy accur before I'm wondering
there way are
doing okay so uh the question
is when we do the cross validation for
that dividing the entire probation into
different fold uh instead randomly
whether you have other way to do the uh
dividing yes of course there are a lot
of way
chronically uh for example you can buy
different uh uh for example like animal
they have different family then for the
breeding material you can come from like
a different Mater breeding material you
can Bas on some like existing knowledge
so then you talk about uh uh another way
is
uh uh based on the fenot T yeah this one
I I don't have a very clear answer
because this one you touch your fin
tab uh at very beginning so then that
maybe P has a problem I need to think
about
weather one I can divide based on the
fold then have the different category
then thanks you
again this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu